Hershey's showed this just just
yesterday
Hershey showed this with the
her for she campaign
her for she campaign was for
international women's day and what
Hershey did was they went all feminist
but there was a Twist on it they went
feminist
and then cast a man dressed as a woman
in the role of the woman for
international women's day
my name is Faye Johnstone I'm the
executive director of wisdom to action
we can create a world where everyone is
able to live in public space as their
honest and authentic selves see the
woman changing how we see the future at
Hershey's Canada
why they always pick like not even gonna
just like it's just like the most random
groups of girls ever like what is this
he looks a lot like that that's a dude
right yeah that's a dude and he looks a
lot like the one who stole the luggage
the one that works for the United States
government it's funny they look a lot
alike as a trans guy who uh works for
the government and he was stealing
designer luggage from I saw the baggage
carousels it's crazy yeah nutcase so
women's History Month which is meant to
celebrate that's it like that's right
now yeah it's right now and it it's you
know it's supposed to celebrate all the
things that women have accomplished in
history people like um Marie Curie and
Susan B Anthony and you know any woman
that did something amazing I'm a fan of
Joan of Arc and now we have a grown man
taking up airspace as a woman on woman's
History Month I don't know what you're
so upset about to be honest do I seem
upset yeah no because he's not a real
he's not a real woman and I'm just gonna
say this you're not a real woman you can
do whatever you want go out live your
life wear a dress get your mani pedi get
your gels get your eyelashes done wear
long hair and a wig and and buy some
Spanx have a good time but you're not a
woman yeah I know that's that's
definitely um and women fought you know
for equal rights the right to vote the
right to be able to make their own
choices not that they're doing a great
job of making choices but that whatever
there's a lot going on neither nobody is
it seems but they have the right to do
that and now you're coming in and just
jumping in and saying that you are a
woman I mean this is just ridiculous
that we're dealing with this and a
company as big as Hershey's again which
makes candy which caters to kids another
piece of [__] going into children's
hands another piece of [__] Hershey
why do they do this like what's their
what's their reasoning because nobody
even it gets it's the same thing with
like the Celtics like look at this [__]
right now the Celtics have like the gay
Twitter logo like it's it's a rainbow
and I'm like bro like they're just like
shooting basketballs like what is like
dudes that like to hump each other have
to do with that like why do you gotta
make the Celtics logo gay like that's
just that doesn't make any sense all of
this virtue signaling is ridiculous and
they keep forgetting who who the
mainstream Americans are and how we
don't have any we don't want anything
more to do with this because they
brought it on our kids first of all
second of all I don't care what you do
in your bedroom keep it in your bedroom
no so if it's about sex that's one thing
but this is now at this point more about
the transgenders because the
transgenders have completely hijacked
the rainbow flag and then look at this
too oh dear lord
like what no like no like I don't care
but you know what you know what I'm
doing business with everybody you know
what the funniest part about this is do
you know what this flat this flag is no
that's the trans flag this is the the
black Trans flag because it has the
African-American [__] on how much have
you seen this flag this is like
everywhere it's everywhere now this flag
is everywhere and it's for black Trans
people like like why is this flag
everywhere I see this more than the
American flag that's crazy to me like I
I don't I could count on my fingers well
it'll take somebody look and take a
picture because it's not going to be
that way forever because people have had
it the gays have had it the gays are
separating from this yeah I was gonna
say I could count on my finger how many
black Trans people I've met so like the
fact that it just doesn't correlate I
see Americans every day and then I see a
black Trans person maybe once every year
it's almost as if you could see the
boardroom and be like uh we gotta just
throw the black people in here somewhere
so uh because they don't even know
because remember they all had BLM on
them a couple years ago now apparently
all the problems of the black community
have been solved so they don't need to
do that anymore yeah now they're doing
this what's next I wonder but here's
here's the kind of stuff that is out
there I'm just going to read a sentence
so there's this this other issue of a
woman a tick tocker who is going viral
on Twitter right now because she went to
Target and was looking for boys clothes
in the little boys section and they're
all like pink and rainbows and like
butterflies and things very feminate
looking clothes and so this woke ass
news station wrote about it and said a
recent incident on social media has
brought attention to the fact that some
individuals still cling to traditional
gender Norms when it comes to clothing
some individuals like wear The Fringe
that's the beauty of it they're telling
them that they're the mainstream yeah
isn't that crazy that's that's what they
did in like high school that's how they
brainwashed you it's like this is the
new Norm this is the norm it's like yeah
like the millions of years we were alive
yeah we just we know better than we know
better than everyone else that was
before us see the women changing how we
see the future at Hershey's Canada
Hershey's Canada I know I know everyone
knows
it's so offensive in every way to every
group it seems
it's so offensive that you know
it crossed Jeremy's mind right you know
so actually some of you tweeted it at us
I said this company this I just want to
eat my chocolate but this company is
just rubbing my face in this stupid not
only woke feminist ideology but this
woke trans feminist I uh you know it
crossed Jeremy's mind
but you probably thought
there's no way
there's no way that Jeremy
would actually launch
a chocolate company if he'd if he did
there's no way that he would do it
on the very day that Hershey's launched
the trans campaign right
so Jeremy is a daily word guy I think I
don't know who he is okay because we
launched Jeremy's razors after Harry's
canceled conservatives took on Disney
with hiring Gina Carano after they
canceled her sued the federal government
over the vax Mandate and won
people think
that we can just take on every woke
company when they make these ridiculous
statements of course we can't do that
every time
or can we
you might be thinking how could you have
launched a chocolate company in one day
well they don't call him the god king
for nothing don't wait pre-order your
Jeremy's chocolate now
at ihatehersheys.com
that is ihatehersheys.com
get your he him and she her chocolate
bars today yet another way to stop
giving your money to well corporations
the he him ones have nuts and the in
them and the she her ones do not have
nuts that's far nutless
it's it's
great thank you for a smart way to make
some extra money it is a brilliant way
and I and I love seeing these companies
come out with anti-woke products and
services that I know I'm not
contributing to Insanity yeah that is
funny I can't believe people like
printed off of BLM you know thinking
like that there was people at the top
and they were like let's just keep this
propaganda [__] going and just keep
making millions could have been me now
they're all yeah they're all under
federal investigation so that could also
be you so let's skip that part yeah I'd
hate you just joking
I know
back to Hershey's for a second
Hershey's honestly if I could go back I
would definitely launch some like blmts
and then like Market them on Tick Tock
that'd be hilarious is that that's
that's not a bad way to make money is if
you're making it off of the bozos that'd
be hilarious like they're they're making
joke chocolates you know there was like
the account at leftist or whatever like
at like feminism or something and they
were launching merch and printing money
and then it got exposed that it was a
white guy that owned it and people got
pissed so like everything about what
you're saying is abrasive to like makes
me bristle because I just don't I don't
like dishonesty and I wouldn't even want
to do business with the those people the
BLM you know the people that that
obviously just joking no that fall at
that altar but you know what I was gonna
well I was gonna you know offer you a
chance to convince me otherwise no I'm
not being that serious about it but okay
could have printed I mean it would be
one thing to like to do that and then
give all the money to a cause that you
know they don't like like those people
like a pro-life cause or something you
know
saving babies because it would piss them
off even more if their money went to
something that they really don't like or
you could just show them how stupid they
are and then you just like you you play
chess properly you just fooled them yeah
you burn them even more though that
would be the problem you could just give
away all that money is a weird one
because like once you realize that money
is not like made it's just simply taken
it's it's it's a weird it's a weird
switch to the way you think about it
like even like as like a Creator and you
launch merch like and that difference
but from what you're paying is like what
you're deciding like oh yeah these
people should just give me this much
it's interesting it is but I I encourage
you to not ever forget that there should
be morality 100 releasing those
decisions and the transactions that you
make as a purchaser and a seller no yeah
I mean there totally should be but it is
interesting you're like this guy I could
make an extra thousand do I charge him
an extra thousand you just never know
Hershey's Hershey's
made an error here I think and irritated
a lot of the customers but they they
exposed something that a lot of people
don't understand about the way our
culture works a lot of people believe
that the problem that our society faces
is that we put too much value on our
bodies on material Goods on the stuff of
this world we deny the soul we deny
metaphysical morality we deny we deny
everything right
no
what what this Hershey's ad and
transgenderism broadly what what it
shows you is that increasingly we think
the body doesn't matter at all
increasingly
we live our lives digitally increasingly
we live our lives on our phones or in
the metaverse or online Internet forums
and so we don't think the Body Matters
we think it can all be we Zoom we Skype
It's All Digital we work from home
no this is where the meme of go touch
grass comes from people saying go put
down the screens go outside go do
something go do something in the real
world with real people in real time in
space
because if whatever you want go touch
grass yeah yeah I've seen that you've
never heard of that no probably because
I'm out touching grass yeah I am I'm out
I mean I do a lot of human interaction
if you're seeing the go touch grass meme
you need it interesting you're trying to
say something I was just away for a week
touching grass what do you want me to do
you know I'm trying you know I'm
studying for those of you that don't
know Sunny from when he was younger from
when he was five or six years old up
until he was 16 or 17. he was a hockey
player he was a goalie and he was really
good an ice Topic in Boston no you were
good and uh so now we moved down to
Florida and there's an adult adult
league here that I'm trying to get Sunny
to play in because I think it you know I
think it'll be fun for you to resurrect
that part of your you know your life and
it'll be a cool way to like just meet
some local people so you know I'm
curious I enjoyed just like working and
then traveling am I getting any support
from anybody you would enjoy having you
know local friends too though so I'm
just wondering does anybody want to come
to see how sunny play hockey and and get
on my side with this so annoying it's
crazy so annoying I know mom's trying to
make him go out and play sports and have
a social you know life more so than when
he leaves Town Sports you need the gym
and money I'm just looking at all the
things that I don't ever want to buy
from Hershey's again now because they're
they're again to point out Michael knows
double whammying with it with the overt
feminist [__] and now the trans
[__] there's a lot of Brands Milk
Duds skinny pop Pocky whizzlers York
Peppermint Patties come on Hearts man I
love those yeah uh Hershey's you've
ruined everything
we live our lives as though the body
doesn't matter we're going to come to
think that the body doesn't matter Lexa
Randy likes credenti
if we if we live our lives just like
couch potatoes plugged into the Matrix
where we do everything digitally
then then Matrix where not only are we
going to accept transition we're going
to accept all of it even if we don't
want to because belief follows
our Behavior and the rituals that we
engage in no surprise here
from Hershey's but it's something that
we should all watch out for the rest of
the show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member and use code
Knowles nah bro what do you think about
about you know backing away from and not
doing business with brands that that are
pulling this woke nonsense not doing
business with the brands that do this
yeah like just continuing to buy their
products and switching to products and
companies that are that
I mean that don't play these games I
mean it kind of like depends like like
if Amazon you know Amazon does woke [__]
but it's like how you can't just not use
Amazon Hershey's that's all poison
anyways all their products are garbage
so I wouldn't buy any of their stuff to
begin with I don't know like like you I
came home with Nike shoes and you start
like busting my balls about it and it's
like bro like I'm just wearing swearing
my you're just wearing shoes from a
company that is it's like you know it's
that's like the mom [__] too like you
just like you bug too much about it
because like I'm just wearing it's got
these shoes I'm just rocking them well
you know the longer you support if you
take your money and you put it into
companies that have problems with your
country and they have problems with
white people and they are throwing
gasoline on the fire of racial tension
in this country you're contributing your
money has power well they were gifted to
me so I can't wear them if they were
free I didn't give them money yeah I
wouldn't but that's just me because I'm
not giving them advertising either by
walking around with Nike I threw away
all their [__] I threw away on my
Converse any I don't have if I go buy
athletic wear and it has a little Nike
symbol on it I I I I I I just it stays
in the store I also do that with things
made in China because I'm not going to
contribute to a society that is actively
trying to undermine my country and our
way of life so and and there are times
when you write I have to because certain
products you just can't even find them
made anywhere else I guess I should care
about that more but I'd really just like
I put them on and I was like I think
you're I think some [__] I think
you're a little lost in the Matrix the
fact that you won't that you don't think
about how your money contributes to
these problems yeah I hear you come out
of the matrix it's in the Matrix yeah
you're the I'm so odd in the major I'm
so lost in the Matrix well maybe you got
one foot out but you still got one foot
in just yeah it's just annoying
I'm annoying tonight and it's really not
nice it's just like you hear this all
the time and it's just like you hear
white all the time just you like just
like I get home and it's just like this
what are you wearing Nike shoes for it's
like oh my God bro yeah
five minutes Nike hates white people
don't wear their shoes sorry you're
right you're right that's the thing
you're right so what am I gonna argue
with what are you going to do
send these shoes just to aggravate me
every day now I could see he's just
gonna freaking wear shoes the same shoes
till my head explodes all right thank
you so much for watching make sure to
like subscribe follow me on Instagram at
sunnyfaz and I'll see you later
[Music]
on